we're backstage
in our beautiful test kitchen and ross
and i are going to show you how to make
a quick
and cheerful holiday cocktail and i call
this one
the snowball and you'll see why coming
up we're gonna start with one shot of
espresso all right and you can use
you're just chilling in the fridge i
think
we've teamed up with lg and i've been
chilling my espresso in the lg
instaview refrigerator it's called insta
view because you can knock twice on the
glass
and peek inside without letting any cold
air out
and then you can take just four ounces
of eggnog and
is it eggnog oh this looks so good oh
right
color it's so so pretty it's like
marbleizing
and i'm gonna put just a shot of rum in
mine and
i will represent the mocktail crew
perfect and you can take the coffee out
too if you want to make it for the kids
just have it be fancy eggnog
i have to show you this really cool
thing if you put the spoon in it goes
right around the ball
like perfectly that's very satisfying
it's a very satisfying drink to make
it's called a snowball because we're
gonna pour
this over the slow melting craft ice
spheres
from our insta-view fridge and then the
holiday garnish a sprig of rosemary
looks like a christmas tree and it does
a little miniature candy cane
on the side and then i dust it with a
little nutmeg oh yeah that does make it
look a little more crisp you could also
do powdered sugar how cute would that
look oh
snow wow oh snow you didn't
cheers cheers
this is so tasty check
out the drewberrymore show.com for the
recipe for a recipe